Mr Sanders Thank You mr. chairman um and
I want to thank all of our panelists
being here with us today miss Roman
mentions that on any given night there
are some 250,000 Americans who are
homeless and that's before Katrina so
obviously what we're seeing is a crisis
in America being made worse with the
hurricane what I would like to get some
thoughts on from our panelists is given
the housing crisis that we had before
Katrina given the fact as I understand
that that in the course of a year some
two and a half million Americans will
experience some degree of homelessness
given the additional major problems the
Katrina is causing in terms of
homelessness what as a nation are we
going to do to finally address the huge
housing crisis that we have in America
for low-income people now it seems to me
pretty clearly especially with poverty
increasing in America that the federal
government is going to have to play a
dramatic role if we think that children
should not be sleeping out on the street
and again Katrina makes the need to
respond even more dramatic let me start
off with ms Rome and give us some if if
this Congress actually believed that we
should not have homelessness if we
actually believed that low-income
workers should not be asked to spend
fifty percent of the income on housing
if we actually believe that this country
should be building large amounts of
affordable housing and as mr. Scott said
put people to work at good wages in
building that housing if by some chance
Congress thought we should do that
rather than giving tax breaks to
billionaires what should we be doing
this Roman well I think it would be
tremendous to use this opportunity that
points out what people who are so
vulnerable
in terms of their housing to any kind of
disaster what kind of assistance they
need and of course we have millions of
people who are at risk of homelessness
750,000 93 million a year we're at risk
of homelessness I mean those are people
who are homeless and many more millions
at risk of homelessness it we need a
massive investment in housing to
stabilize people and when you believe
that the federal government should be
pouring substantial sums of money into
addressing the housing crisis okay uh
mr. Alvarez what do you think sir let me
just briefly give you a description of
San Antonio we have 20 we support 25,000
families currently we have approximately
23,000 families still waiting for
assistance and weary homelessness many
waiting as are in public housing and we
received 13,000 evacuees into San
Antonio when they arrived we only had 75
units of public housing that they could
go to and I suspect it was resentment on
part of some of the locals absolutely so
I think and in Arlen is that we need to
to create a production program and focus
on housing becoming a fundamental
component of decent safe and sanitary
living anywhere in America I should
mention to you that I introduced with
over 200 co-sponsors a national
affordable housing trust fund last year
which unfortunately despite widespread
bipartisan support did not get through
the leadership but let me ask miss Daly
what do you think standard I think we
need a lot of tools as mr. Alvarez and
others have mentioned we need many many
tools but the thing that is lacking
right now is a production program for
very low income families with children
my understanding is that we're building
almost no low-income housing is that
correct for very low income families
with children it's very low we're still
building some 202 housing they're still
low income housing being created because
of the low income housing tax credit but
those programs have not produced
increases in housing for the lowest
income families with children we don't
want to concentrate them in
housing projects we need to figure out
how to do that mr. Alvarez's members and
and nonprofit organizations across the
country that have a lot of experience
running the 202 program for elderly and
disabled could could duplicate that
experience for families with children
but it won't happen without the federal
investment bottom line is we need
massive housing production for
lower-income people miss Miller sir yes
what do you think there is definitely a
very strong need for affordable housing
not only in our state's but in in in the
time sorry I the time to spy on eating
move on to two members prior to the Bell
Thank You mr. yes mr. cleaver mr. clay
first is a very short statement I'm
concerned about the environmental relax
a direct relaxation of any environmental
laws I mean we're setting people up to
be flooded again if we're losing 35 to
40 miles of wetlands a year and the
wetland soak up the storm waters we're
studying the people up again and and of
course I think that's a tragic but my
question is this having grown up in
public housing and having seen in Israel
the State of Israel bringing in the
Ethiopian refugees and placing them in
some prefabricated housing where the
Russian immigrants the Jewish Russians
who had come to Israel were given a for
all let's use a term public housing in
three two three major cities and then
when the Ethiopians came they moved them
in and and there was chaos chaos don't
you believe that if we start bringing
the evacuees into communities where
there is existing housing whether it's
trailer parks or or public housing that
we're going to have some some problems
some serious problems
thank you anybody else
no one wants to tackle that one
congressman let me just real quickly may
I thank ranking member waters and the
chairman for allowing me to sit in on
the hearing just one quick question for
mr. Roberson we have far in excess of a
quarter million homes destroyed by the
hurricane we have over a million people
displays we have shortages of skilled
labor lumber bricks and many other
building materials you have many
suggestions for alleviating these
problems we we also have high
unemployment among the citizens that
live in those areas many of them skilled
construction laborers plumbers
electricians and the light will they be
hired would you have a priority on
hiring with the requisite skills that
that you are looking for the correct
certainly we would be we're always
looking for the opportunity to hire
skilled labor in our factories and I
don't know whether these people will be
located adjacent to be able to be hard
but we're always looking for for
qualified people and I think what I was
trying to get to earlier today but ran
out of time is that as you look at the
rebuild of the Gulf South Region there
and in the city of New Orleans one of
the things manufactured housing can
bring to the table to help assist that
area is that because you can have the
combination of off-site and on-site
construction with product that is
aesthetically suited for the environment
that is going to be placed in that is
certainly capable in a factory built
environment because you can then utilize
the resources of local employment for
some of those trades areas and and you
can use less skilled labor because part
of that trade move into a factory
environment that we can speed up the
process that we can help people get into
housing with more affordability and that
we can we can help New Orleans recover
faster if there is a role played by
manufactured housing and we look beyond
the fact that we all think that a house
trailer is what we don't want this
industry has tremendous capabilities to
build product that it's very suitable
and we can do it quickly and we can and
we can do it more affordably than site
bill one of the major problems though
that we still need in in that regard to
do it is we have to look at two issues
one are outdated zoning restrictions in
many areas and another is we really need
Congress to look at sponsorship through
the GSEs and FHA financing to just give
us equal footing with site builders you
know they were the GSEs were started to
give priority for affordable housing we
make the most affordable housing but
we've got the most owners underwriting
standards the toughest appraisal
standards we're discriminated against
it's easier we got people today that
can't buy a manufactured home that
they'll finance a site-built home
something needs to change about that and
I don't know how to do that unless
Congress steps in but I believe if you
look at those issues you can see
manufactured housing can play a vital
role over time to the rebuild of that
Gulf Coast and to solving a lot of the
other affordability issues for America
in general we've raised all these issues
and we've got a big piece of the pie
that needs to be looked at but it's
being overlooked thank you for that
response Thank You mr. chairman and
ranking member thank you i want to thank
thank the panel and again we were going
to try to get an answer today try again
sir today on the numbers i think is a
very valid point and we want to work
with you to in a rapid way with your
issues i thank you so much for your for
your time and when we come back from the
two votes will go into panel to thank
you everyone